So Joe Rogan, uh, um, uh, uh, the Joe Rogan show was canceled.
All shows canceled this week.
You were supposed to have Kanye West on because Joe Rogan's producer,
Jamie got COVID hope you're doing well. Uh, Jamie.
Probably at a Tim Dillon show. Probably at a Tim Dillon show,
but here's the ready for little conspiracy cuties meets weapon in the morning.
I don't believe for a second that Jamie even got COVID okay.
He could've maybe gotten COVID because look, he's got a lot of money now.
They're in Texas. He was probably a nerdy kid growing up.
He doesn't know how to deal with women,
so he might be out trying to get pushed just because, you know,
it's just all new.
And I understand that it's the same reason why Louie jerked off in a plant.
It's just, you know, when you don't grow up as a teenager,
no one had to talk to girls and all of a sudden they come at ya. It's tough.
So that could be one explanation. But the second thing,
which I think is a more true thing,
I don't think Jamie has COVID I don't think anybody has called,
but I think Spotify put pressure on Rogan to make something up,
to cancel all the shows because they know if they interviewed Kanye on Friday
and they give a good interview, that's going to sway boats away from Biden.
Of course it will because Biden, nobody wants to vote for that guy. So,
so it's going to sway votes and they'll go to Connie,
which would of course put Trump in the presidency.
So I think the conspiracy here is that Spotify and all those places put
pressure on Rogan and it's election meddling.
And they do not want Rogan because Rogan could very easily just get another
producer for a week or zoom, uh, Kanye, Western,
and get the thing up on Friday to cancel them all. It's got Democrat,
written all over it to me. And it's simply because they know, for fact,
a lot of people are scared because a lot of people went Epstein's Island.
A lot of people on that travel log, jump onto pedophile do what's right?
No bumper.
Wow.
That's my Freddy's Abe is Patty Bo roadie by Dave short diary.
We're a couple of firefighters who read the New York post and died.
It is what it is. Yeah. It's a little thing called Lauder faulted.
It's what it is. Cause now what do you think of that?
Is that a little on the notes?
I think that's what you call a little of the nose. I mean, you nailed it.
My mind was blown the whole time,
because the thing about me and you is we're figuring out everything. Yeah.
It's just what it is. Unfortunately, we're figuring it out. I mean,
what can you do homeless pick.
You're going to have to click that and we're going to post it.